it's clear south on north there it is
let's go
[Music]
if you can make to the roundabout i'm
gonna go to the golf course and set up
there
[Music]
you might not be able to make it to the
roundabout and i want to try the caramel
fruit now
[Music]
see if whoever's behind me all set up at
my cargo
it's me i'll go to the golf course
[Music]
they're coming into the city
[Applause]
more the merrier
i think that's him there
oh there he goes
shots fired shots fired
stop stop right there
stop right there
just let it be let it be let it be give
it distance get a difference
shut your hands
show us your hands
please
come ahead
you're right
that was close
yep
three cascade go ahead and send us more
units please
a vehicle is stopped
up against the light pole
driver is not responsive
please show us your hands
affirm
can you see anything sean i cannot i
can't see anything
camera's on if they're not
on go on three cascades stage aid
show us your hands man
if you can can you light it up enough
[Music]
show us your hands dude
david
this is important we need you to show us
your hands so we can get you some
other side of
uh
move over here
i'm going to reach in and try to drag
round okay
open the door there we go